[Music]
well they say you are what you eat i
certainly would be a prize example and
in the case of don gorsky from wisconsin
he's a true connoisseur of red meat no
vegan or plant-based counterfeit in
sight in fact he's very specific dom
with his diet because he recently broke
a guinness world record for the most big
macs consumed in a single lifetime so
let's go through his daily routine
he doesn't have breakfast he has a big
mac at lunch and another big mac at
dinner he washes them both down with a
coca-cola and that's it
that's two big macs a day for the last
50 years which adds up to nearly 33
000
burgers it truly is the mack daddy
well don joins me now from his local
mcdonald's obviously
hi don how are you
hi i'm doing fine how are you doing well
it's great to have you i love a big mac
if i had one for lunch today so i'm with
you in spirit but i tend to have a big
mac every eight weeks on average and i
find that's about that's about my my lot
what i want to know is when did your
first love of big mac star how old were
you
i was a 18 year old 18 years old when i
ate my first big mac
i came to the mcdonald's here
and uh i went inside got three big macs
went out to the car and
when i opened up the red carton
the big mac was wrapped in a foil and
when you open it up it was nice steamy
hot and i bit into that and i said this
is the best food in the world
and you basically had
a big mac for lunch and dinner
pretty much every day i think apart from
eight days you've missed and we'll come
to that but for 50 years you've done
that's great
correct
i mean are you not sick of them
uh no i never get sick of them
a lot of people say when they see me
eating one i look like i'm eating one
for the very first time i guess that's
the best way to describe it
it's my favorite food i never get sick
of it so i look forward to it every day
and i understand you're married to a
nurse is she not concerned about the
health issues involved with so many big
macs
um yeah she's a nurse but she's not
worried about my health because like i
say she sees me every day
i never get sick
i never missed a day of work in my life
and so she knows i'm an active person
i'm kind of hyperactive and stuff so i
do burn off all the calories that i eat
and how much have you spent on this
on this diet in your time
okay a good guess is well they start out
at 49 cents and now they're like 439 so
if you average it out it's probably a
hundred thousand dollars
um i don't know if that's the same
amount in england or not
a hundred thousand dollars on big macs i
gotta say don i i actually admire it you
are a living embodiment of what i would
like to be someone who just eats big
macs all the time and looks great
well thank you um i say i'm just blessed
with good health so i i say that helps a
lot well i normally have one a day and i
have that once every eight weeks tonight
i'm about to nubble in
to my my second one
i get it don't you know what time you'll
be caught up to me you know what i get
it
i get it they're absolutely delicious
don great to see you thank you very much
indeed go and enjoy your next big mac
i sure will thanks a lot for having me
on your show brilliant great to see you
what a guy big macs of the future don't
do that at home everybody
you